all right let's briefly discuss the
growing very explosive Civil War within
the Republican party this is already a
fight for the 2024 Republican nomination
it is Trump versus DeSantis both are in
glass houses and throwing many many many
stones let's start with Trump on
DeSantis and then we will look at
DeSantis on Trump on the Trump side
Donald Trump is flipping out and uh
recently called Ron DeSantis fat phony
and whiny which sounds
extraordinarily like projection let's
discuss it Maggie Haberman has a new
book coming out and she wrote an article
about her interviews for the book for
the Atlantic now I know it listened it's
always the same routine all of these
folks they have all the good stuff and
they hold it for their books in order to
sell books it's what it is doesn't mean
that uh any of it is untrue they all do
it and Bolton did it they all did it we
talk about it is it immoral to some
degree yeah maybe I mean here these are
not uh claims about with National
Security and implications but we all
know that they do this in the article in
the Atlantic three conversations with
Donald Trump there is a section about
Ron DeSantis and Maggie Haberman writes
I brought up another potential future
primary rival by mentioning that he had
been compared to New Jersey's feisty
Governor Chris Christie before the two
men faced off in the 2016 primary Trump
replied I was compared to him why I
didn't know I had that big of a weight
problem a small smirk followed then he's
an opportunist I heard that Trump was
describing Florida Governor Ron DeSantis
in similar terms calling him fat
phony and whiny while claiming credit
for making his candidacy in 2018.
um what is with Trump and calling
everyone fat Bill Barr recently called
him fat Chris Christie recently posted
of a picture of a guy at a buffet it's
still not even clear to me whether it
was Chris Christie or not it looks like
Chris Christie but I don't know if it
was and now Ron DeSantis and the
projection is truly incredible and I
think it goes to Trump's insecurities
Trump is obese okay Trump is obese Trump
claims to be
632-39 he's not six three and he weighs
more than 239 and according to BMI which
is not a perfect measure but I think
it's it's more or less right with Trump
trump is obese Trump is a total phony
he says the santhis is a phony Trump
developed a fake persona to run as a
republican Trump was for abortion access
for 68 years of his life and then he
decided he's going to run for president
and he said no no I'm very very pro-life
as he describes it uh and the story he
came up with is you know I met a woman
and I met the woman's kid
and the woman told me I once thought
about getting an abortion but now I have
this great kid and Trump said wow I
liked the kids so much I became against
abortion come on guys Trump's claims to
be religious he's a complete and total
phony which he accuses Rhonda sandis of
being and I've never seen a bigger
whiner than Donald Trump I I I I cannot
think of in the political world bigger
whiners than the Trump family we're the
poor most poorly treated people ever I
was the best president then everyone
says mean things they're all going after
me they're mean all this different stuff
and what we are starting to see here
with Trump and DeSantis as you're going
to see in a moment is that narcissism is
colliding with more narcissism and you
can get some really interesting results
and we may indeed have that in the 2024
Republican primary if both of these guys
run now the numbers in the 24 Primary in
the betting markets have completely
reversed in Ron DeSantis favor and I'm
going to get to that in a moment but now
that we've covered the Trump on DeSantis
part of the Republican Civil War let's
go to the DeSantis on Trump part of the
Civil War